Next Generation Sequencing or NGS is a
powerful platform that has enabled the
sequencing of thousands to millions
of DNA molecules simultaneously.
This powerful tool is revolutionizing
fields such as personalized medicine,
genetic diseases, and clinical diagnostics
by offering a high throughput option with the
capability to sequence multiple
individuals at the same time.
Sanger Sequencing, first developed in the 1900s,
is the gold standard for DNA sequencing and it
is still used today extensively for routine
sequencing applications and to validate NGS
data. It utilizes a high fidelity DNA-dependent
polymerase to generate a complimentary copy to
a single stranded DNA template. In each reaction
a single primer, complementary to the template,
initiates a DNA synthesis reaction
from its 3’ end. Deoxynucleotides
or simply nucleotides are added one after
the other in a template-dependent manner.
Each reaction also contains a mixture of four
di-deoxynucleotides, one for each DNA base.
These di-deoxynucleotides resemble the DNA
monomers enough to allow incorporation into
the growing strand, however, they differ
from natural deoxynucleotides in two ways:
1) they lack a 3’ hydroxyl group which is
required for further DNA extension resulting
in chain termination once incorporated in the DNA
molecule, and 2) each di-deoxynucleotide has a
unique fluorescent dye attached to it allowing
for automatic detection of the DNA sequence.
As a result, many copies of different-length
DNA fragments are generated in each reaction,
terminated at all of the nucleotide
positions of the template molecule by
one of the di-deoxynucleotides. The reaction
mixtures are loaded on the sequencing machine,
either manually onto slab gels or
automatically with capillaries,
and are electrophoresed to separate the
DNA molecules by size. The DNA sequence
is read through the fluorescent emission of the
di-deoxynucleotide as it flows through the gel.
Modern day Sanger Sequencing instruments use
capillary based automated electrophoresis,
which typically analyzes 8–96
sequencing reactions simultaneously.
Next Generation Sequencing systems have been
introduced in the past decade that allow for
massively parallel sequencing reactions. These
systems are capable of analyzing millions or
even billions of sequencing reactions at the
same time. Although different machines have
been developed with various differing technical
details, they all share some common features.
1) Sample Preparation: All Next
Generation Sequencing platforms require
a library obtained either by amplification
or ligation with custom adapter sequences.
2) Sequencing machines: Each library
fragment is amplified on a solid surface
with covalently attached DNA linkers
that hybridize the library adapters.
This amplification creates clusters of DNA,
each originating from a single library fragment;
each cluster will act as an
individual sequencing reaction. And,
3) Data output: Each machine provides the
raw data at the end of the sequencing run.
This raw data is a collection of DNA
sequences that were generated at each cluster.
The differences between the different Next
Generation Sequencing platforms lie mainly in the
technical details of the sequencing reaction and
can be categorized in 4 groups: pyrosequencing,
sequencing by synthesis, sequencing by
ligation, and ion semiconductor sequencing.
In pyrosequencing, the sequencing reaction is
monitored through the release of a pyrophosphate
during each nucleotide incorporation. The
released pyrophosphate is used in a series
of chemical reactions resulting in the generation
of light. Light emission is detected by a camera
which records the appropriate sequence of the
cluster. The sequencing proceeds by incubating
one base at a time, measuring the light emission
(if any), degrading the unincorporated bases,
and then the addition of another base. This
technology is capable of generating large read
lengths, much comparable to the read length of
Sanger Sequencing. However, high reagent cost,
and high error rate over strings of 6 or more
homopolymers have reduced its applications.
Sequencing by synthesis utilizes the step-by-step
incorporation of reversibly fluorescent and
terminated nucleotides for DNA sequencing
and is used by the Illumina NGS platforms.
All four nucleotides are added to the sequencing
chip at the same time and after nucleotide
incorporation, the remaining DNA bases are
washed away. The fluorescent signal is read
at each cluster and the terminator group are then
cleaved and washed away. This process is repeated
until the sequencing reaction is complete. This
system is able to overcome the disadvantages of
the pyrosequencing system by only incorporating
a single nucleotide at a time, however,
as the sequencing reaction proceeds, the error
rate of the machine also increases. This is due
to incomplete removal of the fluorescent signal
which leads to higher background noise levels.
Sequencing by ligation is different from the
other two methods since it does not utilize a DNA
polymerase to incorporate nucleotides. Instead,
it relies on 16 8-mer oligonucleotide probes,
each with one of 4 fluorescent dyes attached
to its 5’ end that are ligated to one another.
Each 8-mer consists of two probe specific bases,
and six degenerate bases. The sequencing reaction
commences by binding of the primer to the adapter
sequence and then hybridization of the appropriate
probe. This hybridization of the probe is
guided by the two probe specific bases and
upon annealing, is ligated to the primer sequence
through a DNA ligase. Unbound oligonucleotides are
washed away, the signal is detected and recorded.
After that, the fluorescent signal, along with the
last 3 bases of the 8-mer probe, are cleaved, and
then the next cycle commences. After approximately
7 cycles of ligation the DNA strand is denatured
and another sequencing primer, offset by one base
from the previous primer, is used to repeat these
steps – in total 5 sequencing primers are used.
The major disadvantage of this technology is
the very short sequencing reads generated.
Ion semiconductor sequencing utilizes the release
of hydrogen ions during the sequencing reaction to
detect the sequence of a cluster. Each cluster is
located directly above a semiconductor transistor
which is capable of detecting changes in the pH
of the solution. During nucleotide incorporation,
a single hydrogen ion is released into the
solution and it is detected by the semiconductor.
The sequencing reaction itself proceeds similarly
to pyrosequencing, but at a fraction of the cost.
In order to be able to showcase and compare the
different technical aspects of each of the above
technologies, the number of coverage that each
run generates when sequencing the whole human,
mouse, Arabidopsis thaliana, and E. coli
genome are calculated and presented here.
The presented data is based on the most
powerful machines of each technology.
For whole genome sequencing data to
be useful a minimum of 30x coverage
is required. As it can be seen, the pyrosequncing
method is only able to sequence the E. coli genome
at enough coverage to result in valid data.
The sequencing by synthesis method, which is
the most popular method currently on the market,
is able to generate hundreds of coverage per run.
In fact, with this machine it is possible
to sequence 15 individuals within 3.5 days.
The sequencing by ligation method also generates
enough coverage for all genomes to be used,
however, it isn’t capable of
generating nearly as much output
as the illumina HiSeq machines. The Ion proton
machine is used mostly in clinical setting,
because it is able to provide a
sufficient size output within 2 hours.
In conclusion, NGS technologies are
increasingly being adopted by researchers
and are bestowing various benefits in terms
of massive parallel cyclic array sequencing.
The common advantage of all the platforms is
the quantity and quality of large amount of data
generated. The decreasing costs of DNA sequencing
by many orders are fascinating. Given the current
status of certain challenges associated with
NGS it is anticipated that NGS technologies
will become as widespread as microarray. It
is also expected that the challenges will
shift from mastering the technology to how
best it can go for extracting biologically
meaningful information from large amounts of
data generated by NGS. It is quite obvious
that these technologies are incredibly promising
in terms of research and clinical application.